[Musique]
euh ben que à partir du moment où on
annonce des des des des mauvaises
nouvelles même si c'est totalement
objectif et et que en effet ça se ça se
réalise il est beaucoup plus pratique de
faire l' ruche beauc beaucoup plus
rassurant et aujourd'hui on vit dans un
dénis généralisé avec avec des gens qui
vous disent mais non va tout va très
bien parce que c'est beaucoup plus
facile à entendre parce que c'est
beaucoup plus confortable parce que ça
bouscule pas les choses et puis bah
jusqu'au jour où ça va mal se passer
parce que ça ça se passera forcément mal
malheureusement aujourd'hui il y a pas
de sortie sans douleur quand vous faites
une bêtise vous la payez à un moment ou
à un autre quand vous allez vous tapez
la cloche dans un grand restant et que
vous bouffez comme un cochon et ben à la
fin on vous amène une une addition il
faut la régler et ben là c'est
exactement pareil on a vécu à crédit
pendant des années on a on en a
largement profiter on a eu la croissance
on a eu bon tout tout allait très bien
et puis ben maintenant faut retomber sur
terre maintenant faut régler l'addition
alors je dis pas ça je je dis pas que
c'est la fin du monde c'est pas une
question de de de survivalisme ou quoi
que ce soit je dis pas aux gens qu'il
faut s'enterrer dans un bonker avec avec
un pistolet mitrailleur à la main ça n'a
rien à voir avec ça je dis simplement on
a fait un certain nombre de bêtises qui
en plus ont été aggravés par des actions
des banquiers centraux et des autorités
économiques et politiques qui n'ont rien
vu venir comme d'habitude et qui ont
géré de la façon la plus la plus la plus
mauvaise possible et que et que donc il
y a un moment où il va falloir payer
l'addition c'est tout ce que je dis et
que l'addition
plus on attend pour la payer plus on
repousse les échéances plus on essaie de
de de passer à
côté plus on aggrave la chose et donc
plus ça va faire mal c'est tout alors
après c'est un discours que les gens
aiment pas entendre parce que ça les
dérange parce que ça les dérange dans la
certitude très
souvent
certitude je leur dirai simplement lisez
un tout petit peu regardez ce qui s'est
passé ailleurs
et vous en conclurez que en effet ça
peut pas bien se passer voilà après
est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a des
solutions auxquelles on n pas pensé je
suis pas certain parce que
malheureusement on est arrivé à un tel
point de de de nonretour et c'est
aujourd'hui général c'està-dire qu'on a
pas on n' pas la possibilité d'avoir une
référence historique puisque ça ne s'est
pas jamais passé à ce à ce niveau là bah
aujourd'hui on navigue un peu à vue la
seule chose dont on est sûr
c'est c'est que ça ne peut pas se régler
sans douleur voilà alors après que ça ne
plaise pas que il y ait des gens qui
pensent que j'en profite et
cetera ça les ça les regarde souvent
leur argumentation est assez pauvre
euh voilà moi j'ai j'ai je quand je je
le dis je n'ai pas je n'ai pas grand
grand chose à vendre je dis simplement
il y a un certain nombre de choses faut
être factuel faut moi je suis prêt à
apporter tous les chiffres qui prouve ce
que je dis j'ai pas de souci avec ça il
faut être factuel et quand il y a des
des choses qui
mathématiquement ne peuvent pas revenir
en arrière sans sans être soldé
auparavant et donc vous
êtes malheureusement obligé de de de de
de prévoir certaines choses et certaines
choses qui vont pas être forcément
drôles la planche habiller normalement
vous aviez de la la création monétaire
qui était corrélée si vous voulez à la
[Musique]
croissance mondiale d'accord la
croissance du commerce et cetera donc on
avait besoin évidemment de de de créer
de la
monnaie alors créer de la monnaie c'est
pas créer des billets c'est des créances
c'est c'est tout un tas de choses c'est
pas simplement des des billets papi donc
normalement vous aviez une croissance
mondiale qui était autour de 3 4 et vous
aviez une croissance s de la de la masse
monétaire mondiale qui était aussi de 34
ce qui était
normal aujourd'hui vous êtes dans une
situation où vous avez une croissance
mondiale qui est plutôt proche de zéro
et vous avez une
[Musique]
croissance de la de la masse monétaire
qui est plutôt autour de 17 18 % donc on
voit qu'il y a déjà un décalage qui qui
colle plus si vous avez quelque chose
qui n'est plus basé sur rien
un de la monnaie papier c'est quoi c'est
je vous prends une une feuille de papier
je vous marque un chiffre dessus si vous
avez confiance en moi je vous ai marqué
100 € ça vaut 100 €. si le gars en
face me vend des marchandises et qu'il
croit dans ce billet qu'il a confiance
dans celui qu'il aimet ça vaut 100 €. le
jour où il a plus confiance ça vaut quoi
ça vaut zéro d'accord ça vaut zéro parce
que ça vaut à peine le prix du papier si
votre monnaie n'est plus basée sur rien
plus basée sur l'or elle est plus basé
sur rien ni sur la croissance ni sur l'
d'un pays qu'est-ce que ça vaut rien le
jour où les gens perdent confiance le
jour où je vous tends un billet et vous
me dites ah ouais mais non mais ça vaut
rien ton truc je veux pas le prendre à
ce moment-là il vaut
zéro c'est exactement comme si demain
vous prenez tous les billets de votre
jeu de poli c'est pareil il y a un
chiffre qui est marqué dessus d'accord
vous sortez vous essayez de vous acheter
une voiture avec si le type qui est en
face de vous n'est pas un crétin total
il va vous dire Monsieur ce sont des
billets de monopolly ça vaut rien ce
dont il ne se rend pas compte c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la la les les billets en
dollars en yen et en euros sont des
billets de monopolie donc ça ne tient
que jusqu'au jour où un pays ou un
intervenant économique dit ah oui mais
moi je reconnais pas ce billet comme
ayant une valeur de 100 ou 500 ou de 50
€ moi je je dis qu'il a il a pas de
valeur à partir de ce moment-là ça
s'écroule donc ce système c'était
Voltaire qui disait
ça au
18e 1729 je crois la phrase de Voltaire
là-dessus qui dit euh un un une monnaie
basée sur la
confiance envers celui qui l'aimait donc
c'est ce qui aujourd'hui c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui est le cas euh
euh retournera invariablement à sa
valeur d'origine qui est zéro voilà
donc aujourd'hui on a encore confiance
pour combien de temps j'en sais rien
mais il y a un moment à force de créer
quelque chose de rien et ben forcément
vous casser la figure pourquoi est-ce
que si c'est on on le voit bien avec ce
le fameux jeu de Monopoly c'est
intéressant comme comme parallèle parce
que si le
banquier vous redonne des sous vous
n'arrêtez jamais le jeu de monopolie par
définition si à chaque fois que vous
avez besoin de VOUS recaver le le le
banquier vous donne des sous le jeu de
monopolie ne s'arrête jamais
donc sur les sur les matières premières
ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que aujourd'hui les
politiques monétaires sont responsables
d'une bonne partie de la hausse des
matières premières et notamment
alimentaire c'est-à-dire que les les ce
qu'on a appelé les printemps arabe ils
sont pas venus comme ça les printemps
arabes c'est pas tout d'un coup des
population qui se sont aperçu que ils
étaient dirigés par des par des des des
dictatures ça faisait 40 ans qu'ils
étaient dirigés par des dictatures ils
sont pas réveillés tous ensemble le même
jour donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que en grande partie d'ailleurs si vous
regardez où ça a commencé ça a commencé
souvent dans le sud du pays et c'est des
gens qui n'avaient rien à à bouffer et
pourquoi ils avaient rien à bouffit tout
simplement parce que le les prix de des
matières premières alimentaires avaient
explosé et pour pourquoi il avait exposé
et ça c'est intéressant c'est parce que
monsieur bernan était
là il suffit de regarder le nombre de
contrats futurs sur les matières
premières pour s'apercevoir que c'est en
grande partie en très grande partie dû à
la politique de Monsieur Bernard quand
il a annoncé son premier quantitative
easing les le nombre des contrats futurs
sur matières premières a été multiplié
par 1000 et sur le 2e qe ça a été
multiplié par 10000 alors moi je veux
bien que Monsieur bernant nous disent
que il est absolument pas responsable de
la hausse des matières premières mais
enfin quand même il y a une curieuse
coincidence si on peut appeler ça une
coïncidence voilà donc c'est vraiment
une il y a il y a vraiment une liaison
entre cette
politique monétaire et le le la hausse
des matières première et aussi la hausse
du du prix du pétrole et donc de
l'énergie
donc il faudrait que ce monsieur arrête
ces quantitative easing parce que ça va
nous mener tranquillement à notre perte
à
[Musique]
tous les retraites bah les retraites on
n aura pas je crois que c'est clair les
retraite enfin ça fait longtemps qu'on
le sait
euh c'est pas c'est pas une surprise
euh il y en aura pas mais si s'il y
avait que les retraité qui était touché
ça serait ça serait
encore ça serait encore bien mais
malheureusement tout le monde va
trinquer pourquoi tout le monde va
trinquer bah parce que il y a un moment
où malheureusement vous pouvez plus vous
permettre de payer des retraites par par
répartition parce que vous avez plus de
de de gens à la retraite que de gens qui
travaillent donc l'équation elle est
assez vite faite he donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que malheureusement le
le système des des des retraites il
sautera vous savez qu'en plus on avait
fait un on avait fait un petit fond de
de compléments pour payer les retraites
il a été euh bien investi par des
gens par l'élite de notre société il a
été bien investi sur des actions et
évidemment ces actions en 2008 elles ont
pris un coup derrière la tête en 2011
elles ont repris un coup derrière la
tête et on n'est pas prêt de revoir les
cours donc on a commencé par perdre
beaucoup d'argent là-dessus je suis pas
certain que il servent à quoi que ce
soit ce fond donc voilà vous êtes
aujourd'hui toute
façon mais pas simplement je vous dis
les retraités tous les épargnants vont
trinquer quand pourquoi pourquoi on vous
a remonté le le le taux du livret A
c'est pas pour c'est pas pour vous
donner de l'argent c'est pas pour vous
donner les 175 % d'intérêt c'est
simplement parce que ça vous ça permet à
l'état de nationaliser l'épargne alors
ils ont nationalisé l'épargne les
Français qui sont toujours contents
qu'on qu'on s'occupe d'eux se sont
précipités dans le livra et pourquoi on
a fait ça bah tout simplement parce
qu'en 2013 figurez-vous que c'est la
France qui sera le plus
gros émetteur de dett d'Europe et que il
fallait bien trouver quelqu'un pour
acheter ces foutus oat et donc les les
les les obliques d'État et que bah ça y
est on a trouvé on a trouvé le le pigeon
parfait c'est celui qui est allé dans le
livr a et puis à un moment ou à un
autre je vous dis soit par le biais d'un
défaut de paiement soit par le biais de
d'hyperinflation votre livre a il vaudra
zéro voilà et merci circuler il y a rien
à
voir c'est une équation qui
mathématiquement est compliquée à
résoudre non mais le problème c'est que
c'est que vous êtes allé trop loin on a
dépassé le point de N tour donc il y a
un moment si vous voulez quoi que vous
fassiez que vous laissiez
filer méthode américaine d'accord les
Américains ont décidé que il était
absolument pas question de faire le
moindre effort et donc il laisse filer
et puis vaille que vaille on verra bien
ce qui ce qui arrivera euh les Japonais
pareil même même politique en Europe je
vous ai dit les les Allemands sont
terrorisés parce que ils savent ce qui
va se passer et donc ils ont pas envie
de revivre
ça mais en attendant on a choisi donc
pour
l'instant une autre voie qui est de dire
on va faire des économies mais le
problème ce que les gens oublié c'est
que aujourd'hui et et hier aussi c'était
pareil qui est-ce qui avait pris le
relais qui est-ce qui faisait la
croissance dans les pays c'était les
dépenses de l'État c'était des des
salaires qui qui étaient versés par
l'État c'était pas le privé qui
finalement apportait de la croissance
donc c'était en grande partie l'État et
et ben quand l'État ne peut plus quand
l'État n'a plus d'argent
euh et ben c'est fini vous n'avez plus
de croissance alors aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe bah vous avez
l'État qui n'a plus d'argent et qui dit
bon benah on va on va faire des des des
des économies c'est pas tellement
d'ailleurs des économies qui fait c'est
c'est il nous il nous ponctionne un tout
petit peu plus donc il ponctionne les
retraites il ponctionne les salaires il
ponctionne bon tout oui mais le problème
c'est que c'est trop tard c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ces politiques là sont
évidemment récessionnistes puisque si
vous si vous divisez par deux les
salaires faut pas imaginer que les gens
ils vont consommer comme des fous donc
c'est c'est évidemment des des
politiques récessionnistes quand vous
avez une récession bah une récession
votre coup de la dette il est à à je
sais pas à 5
% aujourd'hui en Espagne les Espagnols
sont endettés si vous comptez le le le
l'endettement sur
l'immobilier vous êtes à à à largement
plus de 100
% donc ça veut dire que ça vous coûte au
moins 5 % si vous vous faites pas 5 % de
croissance du PIB vous pouvez pas payer
les intérêts on est bien d'accord donc
c'est très simple
aujourd'hui personne n'est en mesure de
payer les intérêts de la dette ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que tout le monde
emprunte mois après mois pour payer les
intérêts de la dette donc votre dette
elle augmente et quand vous avez un PIB
qui est vraiment négatif et ben il faut
en plus emprunter pour euh euh pour
payer les les les budgets et cetera ça
ça veut dire que à un moment votre dette
elle continue à augmenter qu'est-ce qui
va se passer les marchés vont commencer
à se poser des questions sur le
remboursement possible ou pas possible
de cette dette et à à partir d'un
certain moment les marchés se disent ou
là je vais pas me faire rembourser donc
le le le le le le coût du du du du du du
les taux d'intérêt c'est quoi c'est le
c'est le le le le prix qu'on demande
pour justement paraî ce risque de non
remboursement donc ce prix ces taux
d'intérêt à ce moment-là il se mettent à
exposer et donc c'est de plus en plus
difficile de payer les les intérêts de
la dette et donc ça y est c'est pé vous
êtes rentré dans un espèce de cercle
infernal qui fait que c'est le serpent
qui se mort la queue vous pouvez faire
autant d'économie que vous voulez si
vous faites des économies ça pèse sur le
PIB si le le PIB est négatif à ce
moment-là vous pouvez pas payer les
intérêts de la dette et vous donc vous
ne pouvez pas rembourser votre dette et
donc votre dette elle continue à
augmenter année après année et cetera et
donc voilà bon après terminé le le le
alors vous avez des gens qui ont des qui
ont des solutions très simplistes ils
vous disent bah il a qu' pas rembourser
le fameux Yaka hein B yak
faucon donc euh bah si on rembourse pas
oui d'accord donc tous les épargnons
sont ruinés hein par que les gens font
pas le le calcul ils disent oui mais de
toute façon il y a des riches non il y a
pas que des riches le livret A c'est
c'est de l'épargne et c'est pas que des
riches dedans tous les tous les produits
que vous
avez bancaire c'est de l'épargne
d'accord et cette épargne elle est placé
sur quoi sur des obligues si vous les
remboursez pas et ben c'est terminé vous
n'avez plus d'épargne donc il faut
arrêter de de de sortir des solutions
comme
ça qui qui qui n'en sont pas vous
entendez les gens qui disent ah benah
toute
façon la BCE n'a qu'à émettre des des
des obliques sans taux d'intérêt ah oui
qui va les acheter d'acord et puis à
côté de ça vous avez le même la même
personne qui vous dit de toute façon
c'est très simple il a qu'à pas payer de
de taux d'intérêt qui vous dit et les
rendements de vos placements c'est
quoi si' y a un rendement dans un
placement c'est bien qu'il y a un taux
d'intérêt quelque part
donc c'est c'est atterant de bêtises
c'est comme ça
donc les agences de
notation on s'en
fiche c'est terrifiant les agences de
notation ça ça me fait ça me fait quand
même marrer c'est que vous avez quand
même des gens des
banquiers qui payent des agences de
notation pour savoir quoi
penser comme s'il pouvait pas le faire
euxmême penseer
et et et et vous avez des agences de
notation qui leur disent quoi
penser souvent avec trois trains de
retard hein c'estàdire que moi j'ai pas
attendu j'ai pas attendu que standanard
pour et moodis me disent que la Grèce ne
remboursera pas pour savoir que la Grèce
ne remboursera jamais euh et je trouve
triste que des des des banquiers
et des des des
autorités
économiques est attendu que euh standard
and pours leur disent quoi penser sur
sur la Grèce donc j'estime que ça sert
pas à grand-chose
euh sauf peut-être à donner des des
salaires mirobolants à quelques
analystes qui sinon on n'aurait pas de
métier mais c'est tout ça n'a aucun
intérêt moi je je aujourd'hui j'achète
tous les jours des des obliques
corporates j'ai pas besoin de savoir
quelle est l'annotation de standard pour
n dis pour savoir que si j'achète une
une une obligation la fararge à à 2 ans
La Farge va me rembourser c'est une
certitude j'ai pas besoin de savoir sa
note je m'en fiche complètement
donc je dirais à apprenez à penser par
vous-même ça vous évitera d'être
suspendu à la note de standard pour n
dis il faut quand même bien se rendre
compte que aujourd'hui des pays dont on
sait pertinemment qu'il ne rembourseront
jamais leurs dettes comme le Japon sont
toujours noté dou a ou a moin ou enfin
bon peu importe c'est-à-dire en gros si
vous voulez sont toujours notés 17/ 20
quoi en gros c'est c'est un peu le le le
ça le le dans l'échelle des des notes
des agences de notation c'est juste
grotesque alors que on sait qu'il
rembourseront pas donc faut arrêter il y
a il y a un moment
où franchement enfin apprenez à
réfléchir par vous même ça ça ça sera
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus intéressant
après alors maintenant
elles se font elles se font sanctionner
par euh par les États-Unis que ça
déplait souverainement de de se faire de
cette fée dégradée euh bah on continue
dans le on continue dans le ridicule
quoi aujourd'hui l'État américain il
devrait être content il est pas encore à
triple C donc il doit être content
plutôt et et il faut arrêterf ce ce
cirque avec avec les les les les agences
de natation ils ont échoué complètement
enfin on l'a vu avec les subpre tous les
produits subprime étaient notés triple A
enfin bon on voit que c'est n'importe
quoi ça veut rien dire
donc
bah c'est c'est c'est la c'est
l'impunité de toute
façon de de de tous les politiques hein
vous allez pas vous allez pas mettre
monsieur bernan en prison alors qu'il le
mériterait 100 fois parce qu'il est en
train de couler et son pays et
l'économie mondiale sauf que il ira
jamais en
prison vous n'avez jamais aucun banquier
qui a subi quoi que ce soit comme
sanction et ben vous n'aurez pas non
plus les banquiers du FESF qui subiront
des sanctions mais c'est pas c'est pas
étonnant si on en est là aujourd'hui
c'est parce qu'il y a jamais de sanction
jamais personne n'est responsable de
quoi que ce soit donc à partir de ce
moment-là je vois pas pourquoi les gens
continueraient pas aujourd'hui vous avez
vu un banquier qui s'est retrouvé en
tôle parce qu'il avait perdu des des des
milliards vous avez vu un banquier qui
s'est retrouvé en tôle avec le scandale
du LIBOR non jamais donc pourquoi
voulez-vous qu'il s'arrête aujourd'hui
vous voyez quoi vous avez vous avez eu
une alerte quand même monstrueuse en
2008 he on a failli tous sauter en 2008
avec les avec les bêtises des manquer al
on aurait pu se dire bon dans un monde à
peu près normal euh ces gens-là ils ont
quand même eu très très chaud au fesses
ils vont essayer de réguler un peu plus
ils vont essayer de de de prendre moins
de risque et cetera pas du tout pas du
tout vous regardez les bilans des
banques euh pour la plupart ils ont
augmenté euh la BNP nous dit que sont
son ils ont ils ont bien baissé leur
bilan ais ils l'ont baissé de de ils av
avait un bilan qui était au-dessus de
2000 milliards et maintenant il est à
1930 je crois c'est gros gros effort
gros effort et puis pendant ce temps-là
les positions à
terme donc hors bilan de la BMP sont
passés de 46000 milliards à 48000
milliards de de d'euros franchement je
vois je vois je vois pas moi j'ai j'ai
quand même du mal à avir une diminution
du risque là-dedans bon alors peut-être
que on va essayer de m'expliquer qui qui
a plus de risque mais j'ai du mal on
voit la la plus vieille banque italienne
et une des plus vieilles banques du
monde mont pasask qui a fait faillite la
semaine dernière ou la semaine d'avant
je sais plus parce que on a découvert
tout d'un coup que bah c'était pas si
bien ça qu'il y avait des CDS dans tous
les sens et que la paure elle avait
sauté alors qu'on vienent pas nous
raconter aujourd'hui que le risque a
diminué que les les les banques
maintenant maîtrisent les choses et
cetera elle maîtrise rien du tout et et
le risque il a absolument pas
diminué aujourd'hui je vous dis il y a
pas de il y a pas de il y a pas de
régulation dans les banques il y a pas
plus de contrôle qu'avant il y a pas
plus de on vous jette de la de la poudre
aux yeux en vous disant B ça y est
maintenant on a organiser des choses et
cetera on vous parle beaucoup de balle 3
parce que ça ça va mettre un petit peu
plus de de de un petit peu plus de de
fond propre mais le problème c'est pas
c'est pas mettre 1 ou 2 % de de de fonds
propres supplémentaires quand on voit
les positions je vous ai dit 48000
milliards c'est pas parce que vous allez
rajouter 1 % de plus de de ratio Tier
One que ça va ça va sauver les choses et
et et tout le reste découle de ça aussi
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a absolument aucun
contrôle on vous balade pourquoi bah
parce que quand quand on veut organiser
les choses quand on veut essayer de
maîtriser les choses on va voir les
banquiers en 2008 qui sont en train de
se noyer on leur tend une une feuille
blanche on leur demande de signé et on
s'occupe de mettre les les les choses en
place derrière qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on
n pas fait ça du tout on les a sortis de
l'eau on les a séché on leur a donné du
pognon gratuit en leur disant continuer
à jouer avec d'accord donc on les a
remplumé et après on leur dit écoutez
les gars si ça vous dérange pas trop
est-ce qu'on pourrait s'organiser pour
faire une séparation entre les activités
bancaires et les activités de marché
qu'est-ce qui vous répond le banquier il
vous répond va te faire voir voilà avec
un grand sourire en disant en plus si tu
m'embêtes je ne prête plus à l'économie
il prête pas toute façon mais il l'a
fait croire aux autor é politique qui
dit ah non mon Dieu non non non non
faites pas ça s'il vous plaît continuez
à prêter à l'économie ok bon alors tu
rbal ta ta loi à la con là et puis nous
on continue nos petites affaires bien
tranquilles voilà c'est comme ça que ça
se passe et donc vous n'avez absolument
aucune loi aujourd'hui qui soit une
vraie loi qui organise les choses et qui
en effet euh fasse en sorte d'éviter que
les choses comme 2008 se reproduisent
parce que aujourd'hui elles sont
parfaitement capables de se reproduire
et de se reproduire de façon plus grave
voilà sur les paradis fiscaux je
dirais c'est un c'est un c'est un faux
problème on on on on agite euh on agite
la Suisse euh au au bon peuple euh et
puis pendant ce temps-là le del laware
ça continue les îles Anglo-Normandes ça
continue Hong Kong ça continue euh et
cetera et cetera donc chacun a son son
son petit son petit paradis fiscal et
puis de l'autre côté vous avez les les
les Français les Allemands enfin les
Européens qui qui disent ah ben au
Suisse c'est pas bien et puis pendant ce
temps-là là on continue avec l'Irlande
l'Irlande c'est pas un paradis fiscal
peut-être l'Irlande avec 12 et5i %
d'impôts sur les sur les entreprises
c'est pas un paradis fiscal ça mais on
continue avec l'Irlande et et de l'autre
côté on tape sur les les 15 clampins qui
ont les 15 clampins qui ont qui ont un
un compte dans un dans un paradis fiscal
comme la Suisse ou en dehors je c'est
pas c'est pas le problème
les les gros montants les gros les
gros les gros comptes des entreprises et
cetera ils sont pas ils sont pas en
Suisse ils sont ils sont ailleurs
donc et on les y AFF faire entrer en
plus en mettant en mettant l'Irlande en
Europe donc c'est c'est juste grottesque
comme d'habitude mais bah ça fait ça
fait un chiffon rouge de plus qu'on
agite devant votre ne pour vous pensiez
à autre chose
[Musique]
i passer de c'est de mettre un doute sur
tout ce qui sur tout ce qui est
consensuel et sur tout ce qui sur tout
ce qui sort c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui
faut pas prendre les chiffres tels qui
tel qui tombent faut pas prendre les
idées telleles qu'elles tombent et il
faut essayer de les confronter de de de
les challenger de regarder si c'est
cohérent incohérent et cetera
aujourd'hui c'est un boulot qui n'est
absolument pas fait vous avez dans des
salles de trading des traders qui
attendent le chiffre de l'emploi c'est
mieux prévu ou c'est moins bon que prévu
et
puis il décide d'une stratégie vis-à-vis
de ça jamais à aucun moment ils vont
essayer de regarder si ce chiffre est
cohérent avec les autres données qu'on
peut avoir alors vous avez des données
économiques aujourd'hui que vous n'avez
pas c'est-à-dire que essayez de trouver
les vchif du chômage en Europe je vous
souhaite bien du
plaisir en revche vous avez des pays qui
publient qui publie vraiment donc aux
États-Unis il publie même s'il vous
donne un chiffre qui est traficoté de
bon il suffit de de d'aller de
travailler un peu il suffit d'aller
chercher il suffit d'aller regarder il
suffit de d'essayer de réfléchir un tout
petit
peu et vous pouvez à ce moment-là
retrouver les les les vrais chiffres
donc c'est pas très compliqué
euh vous pouvez aussi essayer quand on
vous
sort un chiffre de de de croissance par
exemple en Chine où il est très
difficile d'avoir des statistiques mais
vous pouvez essayer de réfléchir un tout
petit peu vous regardez le chiffre de 7
et demi qui sort et puis vous vous dites
tiens c'est amusant parce que le Baltic
Dry Index qui est qui est qui est le
prix des des du fret euh
entre justement entre la Chine et
l'Occident par navire
euh il est curieusement au plus bas
c'est amusant donc si si jamais la
croissance reparait c'est on aurait
besoin de bateau pour exporter bah là
c'est pas de bol c'est au plus bas puis
vous regardez le chiffre du du du
commerce extérieur chinois et puis vous
regardez le chiffre des importations
américaines puis vous voyez que juste ça
correspond pas c'est amusant donc il y
en a un qui m dans l'histoire c'est qui
c'est les États-Unis ou c'est les
Chinois ou c'est les deux probablement
les deux
euh vous avez tout un tas de choses
comme ça on a regardé on a regardé aussi
les consommations électriques euh il
essaient de nous faire avaler qui font 7
et5i % de croissance et puis il y a pas
de il y a pas de consommation supérieure
de d'électricité donc il y a un truc qui
colle pas euh on a euh euh on a tout un
tas de enfin on a toute une batterie
comme ça de de de de de de corrélation à
établir et euh et il faut euh il faut
essayer de euh euh d'être cohérent il
faut essayer de trouver euh si on nous
raconte des balivernes ou si euh euh
réellement euh il y a un support
euh réel à ces chiffres-là donc euh
aujourd'hui on sait très bien euh moi ma
petite ma petite marotque parce que ça
m'amuse tout le temps tellement c'est
gros et tellement c'est c'est mal fait
c'est le chômage américain le chômage
américain euh aujourd'hui on sait très
bien qu' fait diminuer la population
active et que c'est le le le le la
baisse du taux de chômage n est
uniquement dû à ça pas à autre chose
donc il y a vraiment et là c'est c'est
purement du bon sens aussi c'est pas euh
il suffit pas de sortir d'une grande
école il faut simplement avoir un un
chouill de bon sens on vous dit les
États-Unis
réindustrialise hein c'est-à-dire refont
revenir des des des industries chez eux
et recommencent à à à à à à ne plus
faire que du service mais faire de
l'industrie et puis vous regardez le
nombre de bons hommes qui sont qui sont
engagés dans l'industrie il y en a pas
ils débauchent alors moi je veux bien
qu'on réindustrialise mais je pense que
il y a un moment où il va bien falloir
qu'ils engagent des gens pareil sur le
logement on vous dit le logement est
reparti aux États-Unis ah oui mais c'est
marrant ils engagent personne ils font
comment pour les construire les maisons
elles se construisent toutes seul bon ou
alors c'est des maisons en kit et c'est
c'est c'est les les clients qui les
construisent bon donc il y a il y a il y
a un vrai aujourd'hui il y a des des
vrais il y a une vraie réflexion à avoir
sur les chiffres qu'on vous communique
on sait très bien sur les chiffres
d'inflation qu'on vous B malade enfin je
veux dire tout le monde fait ses courses
tout le monde sait que l'inflation elle
est pas 1 et demi en France bon donc
c'est pas très compliqué ça donc il faut
il faut avoir un tout petit peu de bon
sens et il faut avoir un tout petit peu
de réflexion alors c'est vrai faut
travailler c'est pas facile tous les
jours mais il y a des bureaux d'études
où il y a 300 personnes et et les gars
il vous sortent des énormité en en
permanence qu'il les fassent un peu
bosser les 300 gus hein